a team of botany professors from the  University of Western Australia just  released a study true story that reveals  plants have long-term memory wait is  that really true this is an absolute  true story and according to the study  plants can actually remember being  harmed they have a memory of being  harmed and that that study is definitely  like a legitimate study yeah Andy it's a  legitimate study it was published in a  very well-regarded science journal it's  a true story ah anyway they say plants  they say plants can even remember  something for several weeks imagine if  this whole time plants for watching our  behavior and remembering everything no  weird Andy Andy  [Music]  [Music]  sorry no witnesses  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  sorry sorry I had  bathroom emergency no problem Andy no  problem at all  you